ليشغل الحياه السياسيه والاعلاميه في
الولايات المتحده ونادرا ما تنظر الى
برنامج سياسي من دون ان يكون الحديث حول
دونالد ترامب
وتشير اخر استطلاعات الراي الى انه يتقدم
على اقرب منافسيه الجمهوريين حاكم فلوريدا
باكثر من عشر نقاط ويتقدم على الرئيس
الحالي جو بايدن في الانتخابات العامه
باربعين نقاط مئويه
السلاح الجديد الذي يستعمله الديمقراطيون
في الانتخابات وملاحقه مرشح بتهمه جنائيه
ويصنعون دعايه وهذا من مصلحتي فشعبيه صعدت
الى اعلى مستوى
واستغل محامي ترامب برامج الاحد السياسيه
ليقول ان مدعي عام نيويورك يعمل بتوجيه من
اداره بايدن التي تسعى لاحباط حمله ترامب
الرئاسيه وليشدد ايضا على ان الاموال التي
تم دفعها للممثله الاباحيه
هي اموال شخصيه وليست اموال الحمله
الانتخابيه
هذه اموال شخصيه وكيف ما نظرت الى المساله
فهي اموال شخصيه وليست اموال حمله
انتخابيه
ولو رات هيئه المحلفين او من بعدها
المحكمه في نيويورك ان الاموال هي بالفعل
اموال شخصيه لسقطت هذه القضيه القانونيه
برمتها وبقي فقط الضجيج الذي اثارته
والمخاوف التي تسببت بها ومنها ما اعتبره
الديمقراطيون دعوه من قبل ترامب لاستعمال
العنف في الشارع
كلنا يتذكر الرعب في السادس من يناير وما
تسبب به الرئيس حين ذاك دونالد ترامب
واليوم يقول الامر ذاته وقد قدمت الاف بي
اي اجازا لي وهم مستعدون
يبقى دونالد ترامب صاحب اكبر قاعده شعبيه
في صفوف الحزب الجمهوري وهو يتقدم باشواط
في حملته الانتخابيه على كل منافسيه
الحزبيين وربما ايضا الرئيس الديمقراطي
الحالي
الغنم العربيه واشنطن